sur twitter ce hashtag oui j'ai avorté
elles sont des dizaines de femmes à
briser le silence autour d'un tabou
celui de l'avortement dans le magazine
causette 13 personnalités témoigne aussi
et appelle à prendre la parole
l'avortement un sujet sensible et ce
depuis des décennies des personnalités
qui déclare avoir avorté ce n'est pas
nouveau il ya cinquante ans déjà le 5
avril 1971 des femmes connues ou non
témoignez dans le magazine du nouvel
observateur
c'est le manifeste des 343 toutes
appelées à légaliser les vg parmi les
signataires l'avocate gisèle halimi la
vérité c'est que toutes les femmes
avortent y compris les femmes de députés
et les maîtresses des ministres et tout
le monde ce mal ne le disent pas et nous
lisons le témoignage est courageux car à
l'époque avorter est interdit par la loi
les rares femmes qui témoignent risque
une amende voire la prison face aux
risques encourus la plupart préfèrent
s'exprimer anonymement à l'image de
cette jeune femme l'une des premières à
témoigner à la télé en 1970 ce n'est pas
du tout agréable de se faire avorter
mais
surtout aussi déprimé parce que je
sentais que je faisais quelque chose
d'illégal de biens sentiment de
culpabilité
vis-à-vis de la loi oui mais pas avec
le 17 janvier 1975 la loi va y est
promulguée l'avortement est dépénalisée
c'est une avancée majeure mais malgré ça
le sujet reste tabou dans la société
pourquoi souhaitez-vous que ce
témoignage je reste tout à fait anonyme
parce que j'ai besoin de gagner ma vie
je pense que si comme je dis mon mari et
artisans si nos clients qu'ils ont le
maire de notre commune et tout le corps
et tout ce que vous voudrez était au
courant nous serions une famille rayé
des femmes tentent de faire évoluer les
mentalités mais elles sont rares à
dévoiler leur visage en voici une
c'était en 1999 elle a décidé de ne pas
donner son nom ni son prénom et même 24
ans après la loi veil il est toujours
aussi difficile d'évoquer le sujet
c'est une décision difficile même si
moi j'ai pas eu doute une seconde sur
charlie vg ce que je devais faire cinq
ans plus tard en 2004 c'est la même
chose
l'avortement reste un tabou persistant
la maternité c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui est assez sacré pour
une fille et toute fille doit être une
femme est une femme doit être maire
c'est un exemple c'est certes ibles
aujourd'hui 46 ans après la loi veil la
parole se libère un peu plus chaque jour
à la télé sur internet dans le magazine
causette donc avec le témoignage de 13
personnalités parmi lesquelles la
députée clémentine au temps où l'actrice
anna mouglalis
[Musique]